if you would have been driving through
the hills of Tennessee about 40 miles
south of Nashville on i-65 in the 1990s
you would have come across a very
curious exit called the saturn parkway
and if you would have taken that exit
and gone a little farther you would have
come across something called the donald
efland parkway that was the entrance to
the saturn corporation one of the
boldest most innovative new experiments
in labor-management relations and
organizations of the past 30 years so
let's take a look at what Saturn was all
about and unfortunately why it failed
well Saturn started in the 1980s when a
number of innovative labor and
management leaders said we've got to
adjust the way in which we work General
Motors came to Donnelly Flynn who was
the vice president of the Auto Workers
Union and said we can't build a small
car in the United States competitively
we've got to outsource that work Don and
his innovative way said well wait a
minute why don't we take a look if we
couldn't take a clean sheet of paper
give it to some folks and see if they
can come up with a new way to do this in
short they created what became known as
the committee of 9999 people engineers
accountants frontline workers union
representatives working together the
goal was to go out and find out what we
could do differently to build a small
car competitively in the United States
they came together looking for who is
doing the cutting edge both from a
technology standpoint and from a people
standpoint visited Volvo BMW they went
to Ford they went to Lackey I think they
visited 75 different companies in the US
and abroad and through all of this the
overpowering thing was that there's a
different way of working with people
they created saturn as a new kind of
company and a new kind of car we came up
with five proposals
all three teams come to consensus that
they kind of like proposal number for
Saturn was built on the basis of
partnership principles from the bottom
up they said we'll have teams that
assemble the cars will have
co-management on the front lines at the
first lines of supervision with a union
and a management co-leader we will do
that up through the manufacturing
operations even product development and
strategy decisions will be made in a co
management way well Saturn a lot of
critics but some of those critics were
were silenced in the first couple of
years in fact only about two or three
years after it rolled the first car off
its assembly lines Saturn rose to the
top of the customer satisfaction ratings
it was as satisfying to customers in
terms of sales experience and initial
product quality is any other car built
in the United States you might go as far
as to say that down to the levels of
turning the nuts and bolts on the car
that there was passion and people for
their jobs Saturn enjoyed in the 90s
level of quality performance a level of
brand loyalty that the rest of General
Motors had not achieved but what
happened the traditionalists within
general motors and within the Auto
Workers Union really didn't like it
Donnie Flynn had retired from the UAW
and Stevie okij became vice president he
was not philosophically aligned with any
of these of these partnership joint
management ideas whatsoever you didn't
have a lot of deep support both within
the UAW or among General Motors in
Detroit for Saturn and so Saturn sales
and productivity began to decline morale
of the workforce declined they felt that
they weren't invested in this company
psychologically and they weren't going
to invest new products in the company I
think it's fair to say that the product
was was outdated the way to kill any car
company is to delay the introduction of
a new product because the competition is
innovating the competition is bringing
out new products and without a new
product Saturn was going to lose market
share and began to lose market share
basic math ruled if you have an
organization that maintains employment
security while sales are falling your
overall costs increase we can't do
anything unless you got money and we
were being strangled by a corporation
that didn't know how to handle us we
were the outlaws if you will to make a
long story short saturn limped along it
built a new vehicle at one point called
the saturn SUV called the view which was
very successful but saturn could not
survive and in 2008 General Motors
closed down Saturn as part of its
restructuring activities so what lessons
should we learn I think there are three
lessons that should influence how we
think about bringing about innovations
and new ways of working going forward
first I want us all to remember that
committee of 99 they were an early form
of crowdsourcing they said no individual
could come up with this innovative
design but if we all put our heads
together and we go around the world and
look at best practices we can create
something new something that no one else
could have imagined in ways that we can
work together and it was successful so
remember crowdsourcing as an option but
expect resistance remember those
traditionalists who said this isn't the
way we do things around here and once
the original champions left the
traditionalists took over and they
slowly slowly starved Saturn for
resources and the end was inevitable and
then finally if you're going to try new
ideas and you're going to create new
ways of working together and new
organizations build in a strategy for
sustaining that innovation right from
the beginning so that it will have legs
that goes on into the future there'll be
opportunities to invent new ways of
working again as you go forward remember
these three lessons from the Saturn
corporation
you